I have been honest enough to say if the
anti-religious left and the left is
anti-religious from from Lenin to to
sorrows
if the left had produced
kind intelligent wise people
my religious beliefs would have been
challenged I fully acknowledge it
because I judge ideologies by their
product
and that's why I don't judge people's
theology or philosophy but the left is
is is wrong on everything ruins
everything and most of them aren't nice
I'm not talking liberals you know I make
a distinction Liberals are weak but
they're not bad
okay so another one here so do not be
afraid of anyone
only fear God fear of God is the
antidote to fear of man I know it
because it's operative in my life I
don't give a damn about what the New
York Times writes about me it means
nothing I sleep perfectly fine that
night I don't walk around fearing anyone
and you don't know how liberating that
is that is why one of the three models
of the country is in In God We Trust
not we trust will take care of us it's
God who matters and of course man
matters obviously but not in terms of
fear you can't you you if you don't fear
God you will fear man humans fear it is
part of our makeup it is impossible not
to have fears
but you can liberate yourself from it if
you fear the right party which which is
God I'll give you I'll give you let me
just ask you something on that before
you continue did you always have that
within you I mean you I think you've
always had it as you know for the now
eight or so years that I've known you
and people know this story but at the
height of kovid when I dragged you out
to a trump rally and you literally said
to me unvax you and unvax me I hope I
get covet here and then of course the
media all called for you to die and you
eventually did get coveted and you
survived much to their Chagrin but the
point is you weren't being dominated by
fear was that always in you or was that
something you learned very early yeah I
I I I learned it I learned it and
imbibed it uh it became part of my
nature by the way I just want to make
clear it was it was partially
tongue-in-cheek about wanting covet what
I did want
was a way to get antibodies you said
that for sure and and you know I I'm not
an idiot obviously but I I I turned out
right I turned out right when I said
that the lockdowns were the greatest
International mistake in human history
and and and and and they were they were
devastating keeping kids out of school
for two years was a crime literally a
crime it was a crime against children I
you know look we both feel this way I
you know I don't know I don't have to
belabor the point but
uh the let's put it this way I wrote a
piece about 20 years ago how the left
keeps me religious you'd love it you
should take a look that might explain my
religious revival over here that yes of
course it would
I have I have been honest enough to say
if the anti-religious left and the left
is anti-religious from from Lenin to to
Soros
if the left had produced
kind intelligent wise people
my religious beliefs would have been
challenged I fully acknowledge it
because I judge ideologies by their
product
and that's why I don't judge people's
theology or philosophy but the left
is is is wrong on everything ruins
everything and most of them aren't nice
I'm not talking liberals you know I make
a distinction Liberals are weak but
they're not bad
um you know it's interesting because as
you know we we just had Justin a couple
weeks ago and we've got number two baby
number two on the way but we did we did
the bris at eight days and you know it's
if you look at it from a purely secular
point of view it's it's somewhat of a
crazy thing to do you bring this perfect
thing into the world and then and then
you're cutting this child that's what
you're doing and I remember we David and
I had this talk before about you know
our our thoughts on everything and my
overriding feeling about it was that my
parents did it their parents did it
their parents parents did it and Way
Beyond that for something like
5783 years three thousand well really
thirty two hundred yes yeah that or four
thousand actually four thousand right
the calendar but we go back to Abraham
okay but the point is that it's been
done for a long long time and I felt
that that am I just wiser than everyone
that came before me oh God bless you oh
that's so the perfect reaction and
that's what they believe they think they
are let's believe they are the best
people who ever lived
they do that's why they tear down
Lincoln and Washington we are better
than them they don't hold a candle to
these people by the way I just want you
to know I I have two sons as you'll have
God willing and I had uh I don't cry
easily
and I was with the two times I most
remember sobbing
was at their brisk at their at their
circumcision exactly for what you said
holy crow
this goes back 4 000 years I'm not
prepared to end it it just felt crazy to
me like no I just know so much I just
know so much I won't do this thing the
people before me were so dumb it's it's
it's it's almost grotesque in a in a
bizarre sense to think that way but do
you think that that so you're writing
this book as all of this coveted
craziness is going down and you're
you're making this distinction between
you know politics and having a religious
worldview or just something that's not
politics and then you see the people in
the name of science uh sort of become I
wouldn't say religious they became
cult-like in their following of this
stuff that must have been interesting to
be writing this at the same time
okay
all it did is reinforce everything I was
writing and and everything do you know
that there's another law in the Torah
uh to give you an idea of how
contemporaneous this stuff is do not
follow the majority
to do bad
I could have put that one on Twitter
Dennis is that mind-blowing
a Biblical law
do you think somehow that religious
people didn't sell this stuff well
enough like what what do you think
happened correct is that you're right
that you hit it Dave you're so in touch
with everything it cracks me up talking
to you is such a joy likewise that's
that's that is thank you that is exactly
correct
the religious are as responsible for the
rampant
non-religiosity as an anti-religious
armor that is exactly do you think that
goes across across religions from a
western census oh completely Christians
failed to teach religion properly Jews
failed to teach religion properly they
all relied on
uh inertia
I'm religious my kid'll be religious end
of issue by the way Americans did it as
Americans Americans didn't sell America
to their kids
you you and that's another law in
Deuteronomy you have to teach these
things
diligently to your children when you
wake up when you go to bed when you walk
by the way the these are all it's so
brilliant you can't stop and it's
perfect to tell you because you're gonna
have you have one and a half or one and
three quarters
you got Dave you you guys gotta talk to
your kids about values constantly I
think I know I drove my kids crazy I had
one message I don't give a damn about
your grades
all I care about is your character have
a great day
and your kids are pretty good I know I
know David particularly yes that's
correct that's correct and they play
that recording by the way my older son
whom you know better also David the one
straight David at the table
I said I I there's one straight I gotta
say that it does if he cracks me he
cracks me up in General David but uh he
he has in he he has one complaint
against me you're gonna love this
because if you don't have a complaint
against your father you're not normal so
he has one complaint that I know of okay
I can't speak about others that I don't
know of dad you didn't push me hard
enough in school and he's right I didn't
I in fact I said I don't care if you do
your homework I care about your
character
very few parents say that but I'll tell
you something you get better character
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
spirituality instead of non-stop yelling
check out our spirituality playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell